a single completely standard generic
democrat
crushed four right-wingers on fox news
related to the fbi search warrant served
at trump's mar-a-lago i'm talking about
jessica tarlov i'm like no big jessica
tarlov fan
she's intelligent she's a completely
standard democratic party apologist not
someone whose political views are super
exciting to me but i have to give her
credit she holds her own when she goes
on these fox news programs she was on a
program called the five
where there are i guess it's like
there's four
sort of hosts and then
a fifth person who they often put in the
middle as you can see here in this
particular episode it was right wing
bomb thrower dan bongino who was brought
in and every single person on this panel
i believe it's going from left to right
here
degan mcdowell
then it's jessica tarlov dan it's
bongino then i believe that that's dana
perino although there's like 50
different
um
you know blonde news women on fox news
and it's a little zoom zoomed out i
can't tell who that is and then on the
far right is greg gutfeld all right
wingers
the topic is the search warrant served
at mar-a-lago
and they try all of them to use these
very often repeated but factually
incorrect talking points about trump
complied with the subpoena for the
documents but actually he did all these
different things and tarlov is taking it
from all sides and fending it off quite
well i have to tell you president has
had to comply with and why now because
they subpoenaed him in june and he did
not comply
no i'm not i can't i don't know no i'm
not she's not making it up
the trump lawyers claimed that trump
complied with the subpoena but the fbi
knew better and they knew they hadn't
gotten the documents back it's sort of
like if you say i am bankrupt that
doesn't mean you are bankrupt you can
claim to be bankrupt i'll go even
further the alex jones example
you can file for bankruptcy that doesn't
actually mean that you were bankrupt it
just means you have you have made a
legal assertion that you are bankrupt
trump's lawyers said we gave you
everything they didn't okay so that
there's there's one aspect and then it
just continues yeah you are he actually
met with them on two third according to
multiple meeting with someone understand
the subterfuge and the distortion
meeting with fbi agents doesn't mean you
complied with the demand to return all
the documents these are two different
things and jessica tarlov realizes that
i actually met with them on june 3rd
according to multiple yes and then after
that james bratt who was the agent
involved in this who does overseas it
was six weeks it was six weeks since the
end of june and that was okay so then
they interrupt her now degan mcdowell
comes in with look at how look at how
slowly they moved it took so long for
them to act it was six weeks it was six
weeks since the end of june and that was
the last communication
if it was so urgent that was so urgent
was there a subpoena ignored by the
trump
mcdowell is now using another talking
point this is a very common talking
point they're using which is if this was
so urgent if it was so urgent and of
national security consequences that
trump had these documents you know in
his toilet or in his bathroom wherever
he had him at mar-a-lago if it was so
urgent
why did they slow play it so much why
did they allow six weeks to to go by
between the june 3rd meeting
and serving the search warrant this is
one where they want to have it both ways
imagine that the fbi did something
totally different imagine that the fbi
didn't give trump the six weeks they
just went in and went looking for the
documents these very same right wingers
would be saying this is not a way to
treat a former president
they should have done it through lawyers
they should have given the opportu given
him the opportunity to return the
documents it's too aggressive to go in
so quickly so do not fall for that
talking point they're saying
the f b i moved so slowly it couldn't
possibly have been of not of security
consequences if the fbi moved quickly
they would have said that's an
inappropriate way to handle an
investigation into a former president
and again jessica tarlov just doing
everything she can to refute this
nonsense subpoena ignored by the trump
they had conversations after the
subpoena multiple conversations
they handed over surveillance tapes just
know whether they comply it or not okay
so again
the question is did they comply with it
just because you had conversations after
the date doesn't mean you did what the
subpoena instructed you to do and then
just one other really funny moment
bongino couldn't help but bring up
hillary clinton
and i really like how jessica tarlov
here
looks at her watch and says wow you made
it nine minutes before mentioning
hillary it's on the democrat side
hillary clinton literally paid a foreign
spy paid a
foreign party as a paragon don't make me
laugh
they can't help themselves that
this can't just be about the facts it
has to be about hunter biden's laptop or
when hillary clinton oxycleaned emails
or whatever the case
it can't just be about the facts and
really nice job there done by jessica
tarlov
one of our sponsors is better help the
customized online therapy service that
offers video phone and live chat with
your therapist you don't even have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to you fill out a questionnaire to help
assess your specific needs and then
you're matched with a licensed therapist
in under 48 hours you can schedule
secure video and phone sessions you can
exchange unlimited messages with your
therapist and you can request a new
therapist at any time for any reason at
no charge talking to a therapist doesn't
mean there's something wrong with you it
means you're doing something for
yourself and for your wellness you get
your car serviced you work out you see
the doctor to prevent physical illness
and disease
therapy is the same thing anyone can
benefit from it i think it's very
important join the two million plus
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with better help get 10
percent off your first month at
betterhelp.com pacman the link is down
below